you are competing with
your lovely
past they'll see how i do
this is the academy's 90 seconds
so i'm gonna hit the timer okay
everyone's asking you questions all
right all right okay let's just do it
whatever
what movie does robert de niro's famous
line are you talking to me taxi driver
yes
uh rydell high school studying for which
influential 76
greece
yes how many total grammys did aretha
franklin win
13
julie andrews won the best actress oscar
for which 1964 musical
um
what do you call it
which was the nanny uh
yeah uh yeah
okay
harry potter very promise right what
time did arifa sing in the 1880 film the
blues brothers oh thank you
yes
jody foster played fbi agent flurry
starling in what 1991 film uh
silence of the lamps
oh you're doing great okay what was the
first feature animated movie released in
history
snow white and some of joris
yes okay which 90s movie has the best
selling fabric of all time has it been
which 90s movie has the best selling
center of all time 90s movie
oh [ __ ]
like
can you give me another hand
is it a music
what is your favorite aretha franklin
song
uh
i think
uh think
okay we're gonna give you another try oh
respect
boom there it is
you